TAKAYUKI YOSHINO: My
name is Takayuki Yoshino.
I'm a medical doctor working on
National Cancer Center Hospital
East.
Today I was happy to be here,
and to be given the chance
to present here.
So I would like to talk
about the clinical value
of the virtual sequence.
This is a new concept, utilizing
nationwide cancer genome
database.
So first of all, I would like
to show you the current cancer
treatment.
There are four pillars,
including the surgery,
and chemotherapy,
and the radiotherapy,
and the immunotherapy.
These are very important
to patients, to be cured,
or the palliative to prolong
the overall survival.
So more focusing on the
advanced case, stage four
and the [INAUDIBLE],,
chemotherapy
and the immunotherapy
are the central mainstays
for this advanced disease.
So currently, there are so many
pharmaceutical company intended
to clinical development,
using the chemotherapy
and immunotherapy
and the surgery.
So this is a very
important curve.
This is a survival curve,
using the [INAUDIBLE]..
You can see this
dotted line means
the survival rate, each time.
X-axis showing the time
from the treatment.
And you can see the survival
goes down, and goes down,
goes down.
This means patients
pass away, died,
during that critical course,
not using any chemotherapy.
However, patient who received
some conventional therapy,
a state of the art, best
of treatment to date,
so far, the patients'
survival go up, comparing it
to the dotted line.
The dotted line means the
best of supportive care.
So however, 2015,
Obama, President,
stated, the precision
medicine initiative.
This means the
corresponding therapy,
what Gene X abnormality.
This is called a
precision medicine.
If a patient receives such
a [? feat ?] treatment,
you can see here that the
survival rate goes up, and goes
up, goes up.
There's some
patients being cured,
even in the patient
originally diagnosed
for the advanced stage.
This is [? approximating ?]
to receive the patient, less
saving.
Such an precision medicine,
corresponding [INAUDIBLE]
where the Gene X. So we created,
initiated SCRUM-Japan Project,
since 2015.
This is a nationwide, general
cancer, general screening
project, including lung cancer,
LC-SCRUM, and the GI-SCREEN.
This is a gastrointestinal
cancer in turn.
There's so many
pharmaceutical companies
here joining in this project.
More than 200
hospitals across Japan
also joining in this project.
The data center, and [? Adobe ?]
[? restorative ?] office is
coming across LC-SCRUM
and the GI-SCREEN.
So participating free, from
a pharmaceutical company,
while spanned by the measurement
of the comprehensive,
and next to generation
sequencing task,
by the [? center ?]
[? bender. ?] This is
the overall picture of
our SCRUM-Japan product.
So to date, this is the
achievement for ourself.
You can see here that
30,000 patients received
next generation testing.
You can see here
that 300 patients
enrolled in critical
trials, either investigated
initial trial, as
well with a company
sponsor, clinical trial.
More than 270 hospitals across
Japan also be participating.
Ongoing clinical trial, 50
ongoing critical already.
There's 17
pharmaceutical company
included in this project.
Of course a domestic company,
as well as the international
[INAUDIBLE] company also.
To date, our
achievement here, who
approved drugs, who approved
companion diagnoses,
already achieved.
As you can see here
then, all the detail,
critical, psychological, genome
data sharing, on time sharing,
with academia [? forum ?]
already achieved.
So this is a big, large scale
data set, already we created.
So however, one of
the big problems.
NGS testing takes too much time.
You can see, two
whole weeks needed
to get a result to each patient.
Because more than 100
genes, simultaneous
measurement, or with
a more than 100 genes.
So we spend too much
time, two whole weeks.
So a brighter future,
considering the brighter
future, minutes with
second level, testing
will be realized.
It's a very excellent
news to the patient.
So I proceed.
This is the flow of the
initiating cancer treatment.
Current critical cancer cause.
The patient has bed at the
hospital, and then the biopsy
to overtake tissue,
cancer or no cancer.
We discriminate, this lesion
is cancer or no cancer.
The pathological diagnosis.
This is a [INAUDIBLE].
One to two weeks scenario.
After that you can
see, additional slides
are needed for energy testing.
Spend two whole weeks
[? double ?] to score.
You can see here.
So patiently waiting for
at least three to six weeks
to start the treatment.
It's a very long
time for the patient.
So I would like to ask you.
If you, your family, are
diagnosed with cancer,
you choose immediate,
conventional [INAUDIBLE]
therapy?
Or three to six weeks
later, a precision medicine.
Which one do you
do you love here?
Here?
So you are waiting for
the three to six weeks.
Very long time, if
you are have cancer.
AUDIENCE: Depends how
long I have to live.
TAKAYUKI YOSHINO: OK, OK.
But I guess the best scenario
here, immediate precision
medicine.
Note those, no time--
no waiting time-- it's
a very important issue.
So I guess the new concept
here, the virtual sequencing.
If we are meeting here, testing
a weeks, two whole weeks,
or meeting this two
whole weeks, this
is only in a few
minutes of second level,
we call this virtual sequencing.
So I guess if the
next year, 2020s,
we achieve the minutes or
second level diagnosis,
called a virtual
sequence, what we realize.
All patients are happy, I think.
So this is a very critical
value of the virtual sequencing.
So methodology here.
[INAUDIBLE] way.
You can see the
hematocrit [INAUDIBLE]
data pathological examination,
it's a [INAUDIBLE] way,
worldwide.
You can see all the steps.
And then the
directory diagnosis,
genetic alteration,
skipping dissection,
and [INAUDIBLE] testing.
So we use our largest
scale database.
We now conducting the--
learned by the training data,
using our largest scale data
set.
And then we also created a
virtual sequence algorithm,
has been validated by
the verification data.
This step is very
important to our data,
make it "Mission Impossible"
project possible.
So this is a preliminary
result. You'll
find X, what Gene X
predictors are already,
are used in their
clinical practice.
But it is confidential.
We cannot disclose this gene.
However, you can see
preliminary results show,
you see 0.94, which means the
near perfect the concordance,
near perfect concordance,
between the real sequencing
and the virtual
sequencing, I guess.
So this is AUC.
It's per patient data.
So nearly 95%, 96%
of the concordance
we achieved already.
So looking at the real
energy sequencing,
you can see the cost thousands
of the dollars, each test.
However, we realizing that
in virtual sequencing,
I guess, realizing
low cost each test.
It's a very important huge
leap, in fact, on saving cost.
So this is the final slide.
Overall SCRUM-Japan
GENESIS Project.
This is the first step to
use the additional virtual
sequence.
We have a lot of the database,
baseline equal critical,
equal space [? meaningful ?]
chemotherapy history
on the genomic info,
and [INAUDIBLE]
and a medical history,
and so on, and so on.
So this database is grossing,
grossing, because of the input.
Several hospitals
update it already.
And also we have a lot of
the IT company, [INAUDIBLE]
and the crowd [? race ?]
under the Google,
having a chance to
use the GCP platform.
So I guess we are next
generation topic, [INAUDIBLE]
platform, GCP, are shifting
from another crowd, which
will be the monumental win
to prove the GCP value,
and the credibility with
a huge [INAUDIBLE] effect.
So my presentation is finished.
And the moving to
the second speaker,
the chairman of the Cloud Ace,
Yoshizumi-san [INAUDIBLE]..
Next speaker.
AYATOSHI YOSHIZUMI:
Thank you very much.
I'm sorry, I'm not so
good at the English.
So now I speak Japanese.
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[APPLAUSE]
ARIE MEIR: Hi, folks.
So today, you had a chance to
hear from some of our customers
and partners about a very
specific application,
very specific use case
that they are solving for.
So Yoshino-san's team
is working on developing
this tool, virtual genomics,
that essentially uses
some data from the medical
images, from pathology images,
and shows that it's equivalent
to genetic information.
So that would help
save time, and help
reduce anxiety for cancer
patients during diagnosis.
And Yoshizumi-san
presented how their usage,
of how their cloud
journey has progressed,
and some of the
tools they've used.
My goal is to give
you a little bit
of an overview of how cloud
health care team, which
is my team, is thinking
about the space,
and how we approach the product
development in this space.
Before I do that, I just
want a quick question.
How many people here
would consider themselves
in the health care sector?
OK, roughly I see 50% of people.
And how many physicians
are in the room?
OK.
Sir, we know who to
call if we need CPR.
Thank you.
This gives me kind of
sense like where to point.
So let me start from this slide.
So this is a paper published
by Professor Anupam
Jena, who is a Harvard faculty.
He's a medical professor, a MD.
He's also a PhD in economics.
And the only reason
I bring it up,
his credentials here, is that
let's assume for a second
that he can run and properly
design an experiment.
So the experiment that he
designed, or the question
that he asked was, what happens
when American Heart Association
organizes a conference?
In the US, there are
30,000 cardiologists.
And once a year, they
go to a conference,
usually in San Diego.
And a week they're away
from their hospitals.
70%, seven zero, percent,
of these cardiologists,
leave their hospitals.
Now something might happen.
You know, you look at
the data, like what--
who thinks here that
the patients got worse
during this time?
Who thinks the patients got
better during this time?
So that's actually true.
That's what he
says in the paper.
There is data that suggests
that if you are hospitalized
with acute cardiac situation,
condition, during the week
that all the cardiologists
are in a conference,
you have better
chances of survival.
And the data is there.
You can take a look at it.
He turned to ACC and AHA,
and he got no comment.
The way I interpret this
data is that it suggests
that sometimes the decisions
that are made in the health
care system are not
always in the optimal,
best interest of the patient.
Right?
We see this through this data.
And when you look into how
health care data is used,
and how health care
decisions are made,
you realize it's very complex.
Right?
And I think that the
position we're trying to take
is coming from a
very humble place
here, and trying to ask
ourselves where technology,
or where data organization,
can play a role.
Because sometimes it cannot.
In the emergency room, you
need to make quick decisions.
There is no time to
look at a computer
or look up data information.
You need to make judgment calls.
But sometimes you can use
data in a more effective way,
and that's kind of our mission.
So what we want to do is to
help our customers and partners
organize the world's
health care information.
There is a lot of
information out there.
We see data that imaging
data, genomics data,
is doubling now
every several months.
So how do we help organize it?
How do we make it secure?
And how do we make it useful?
Right?
So secure and
accessible, this is
kind of the core infrastructure
or the core cloud capabilities.
And then how do
you make it useful?
This boils down to analytics
and machine learning.
These are hot themes.
At every booth you go,
you'll hear about it.
My goal in this
short presentation
is to give you a little
bit more specifics.
What does it mean for us
in the health care space?
So when we think about
what we are building,
like if you ask like,
what is Google Cloud
health care is doing?
So we think of our offering
as a data platform,
that is meant to enable
providers, researchers, to ask
and answer new questions using
the information that they have.
And we think of this
platform in three layers.
There is the data platform.
I'll go into each
layer specifically.
But there is a data layer, there
is the cloud services layer,
and then there is the
applications layer.
So let's talk about
the data layer first.
So the data layer
basically means that you
have a lot of information.
If you're a health care
provider, or health care payer,
or a research organization,
you have a lot of information
that your machines, or your
patients is generating.
You need some sort of way
to organize and manage
this information in the cloud.
So what we have built
and released-- right now
it's in beta-- is
a set of services
that allows you to manage
standard health care data
types in a fully managed way.
So what that means is that
we have a DICOM endpoint that
runs in the cloud.
We have a service that
can manage HL7 V2 data.
We have a services
can manage FHIR data.
So these are kind of
the fundamental pieces
of any health care data,
or health care data set,
or data warehouse.
Now I'll give this example of a
super high level overview of--
I wouldn't even call
it architecture,
but maybe a meta architecture.
And we showed the demo
at the conference call
RSNA, which is the radiology
conference in Chicago.
It happens every year
around Thanksgiving.
And what we showed there is
basically an off the shelf
medical imaging device that
connects through the cloud.
Our cloud can speak
DICOM natively.
So that means that you can
just connect our cloud,
and then just any
medical imaging
modality or medical
imaging device,
so the data arrives
to the cloud.
And then from there,
you can either
visualize it using something
like a zero footprint
viewer of your
choice, or you can
run additional computation,
analytics applications, on it.
In this case, what
we have done, we
use the tool called AutoML,
Auto Machine Learning.
I'll talk about it in a second.
But we train a very
simple AI model
to separate between a hypoechoic
and a hyperechoic ultrasound
mass.
Now what that means
in very simple terms
is that we were able to separate
water bubbles from air bubbles.
Now it's a simple
demo, so this was only
shown for demonstration of
capabilities of the technology.
But we have right now
customers and partners
that are using these tools to
develop clinical applications
on real data.
So that's the piece I
want to communicate here.
The other piece is
the public data set.
So this is especially
relevant for researchers.
If you're trying to
test a hypothesis,
then you need to have
access to some data
to be able to test
your algorithm,
to test your application.
Right now there is
a lot of data sets
that are public, in
the public domain.
But to get access to them
it's not straightforward.
You have to download them.
It's like oftentimes, it's
like large, terabyte scale data
sets.
You have to make sure that
your tools are compliant
and they're compatible
with these data sets.
So we want to
simplify the tasks.
So we have taken data sets
that are already public,
in the medical imaging
domain, in the EHR domain,
in the genomics domain, and
we host them on our platform,
so that you can come
and test out your tools
on the data that
is already public,
in a more straightforward way.
So let's say your data is in
the cloud, kind of mentally.
Your data is in the cloud.
The question is
like, OK now what?
And this is where it depends
really what you want to do.
The way we see our customers
and partners using the services,
and running on
top of their data,
is kind of one of two buckets.
One bucket I would roughly
call the analytics,
and the other one would be
the machine learning side.
So in the analytics
space, this word
is probably one of
the more overused,
especially in a
conference like this.
So this really depends,
like what is the question
you're trying to answer?
Like for example, if you
have an expensive resource,
like a physician, or a
certain piece of equipment,
that is very scarce,
and that creates
a bottleneck for your system.
You might be interested to
see, how can I maybe overbook
that resource?
How many people have
ever in a flight
in an airplane, or in
the airport, and you've
been offered like, hey,
if you have flexibility,
we will give you a
hotel or maybe $500
so that you can stay and
take the next flight?
So imagine you
could do something
similar with an appointment,
doctor's appointment,
or a specialized
MRI appointment.
So this could be an example
of an analytic query.
So BigQuery in this context
is one of our products
that enables you to
analyze large scale
data, petabyte scale data.
It's an enterprise data
warehouse implementation.
So the other piece
I would mention here
is de-identification,
especially if you're
trying to do some sort of
research collaboration.
You have clinical data that has
protected health information
like names and addresses.
It has also, a lot
of times things that
are not necessarily
immediately identifiable,
but can help you narrow down.
Imagine you're writing, oh
a mother of 10 children,
in a town.
Or the CEO of such a
company came to visit today.
Right?
So this information is
not directly identifying,
but it can lead to
exposure of PHI.
So we have tools that enable you
to de-identify data, text data,
medical imaging data, that
are built in cloud services.
Now this problem
specifically, we
were very interested
to solve this,
because this is
something that we
see every research team
reinventing the wheel
and building their own.
And there is always
questions I get.
Well can your tool detect
a pacemaker serial number
in a CT image?
So in this case it probably can.
There is always, the
next questions like, well
can it detect the name of
a patient that is written
on a grain of rice in Sanskrit?
Because that's a patient that
I had, that came to a CT.
And the challenge I
want to bring up here
is that we have data
that shows that even when
people are doing
this task manually,
they will still make mistakes.
So you cannot devise
a perfect tool,
but so the path we chose
is we implemented our tool,
and we also connected
existing open-source tools,
so that we can offer
our customers a choice.
And you can compare and
contrast on your data,
because that's
the ultimate test.
A couple of things on the
natural language processing.
So we're working
with customers that
are solving challenges like a
trauma patient is rolling in.
I have three different
radiology reports,
because they had been taken to
a head CT, and a spinal X-ray,
and another lumbar CT.
And these, because of
the different machines,
different rooms,
they were written
by three different people.
Can I devise a summary that
will very quickly tell me
what do I need to worry about?
What is the most risky
thing for this patient?
So this is leveraging
heavily NLP capabilities.
Anytime you want to use any
type of machine learning,
you want to have labeled data.
So we have solutions
for enabling
you to label the data that you
already have, to create labels
and to train AI models.
Speaking of AI
models, here there
is different categories
of applications.
So some applications
are kind of operational,
like help me predict
when I'm going
to have a spike in demand,
so that I can anticipate,
that and I can maybe
invite more nurses.
Like if I have an epidemic,
or a flu epidemic,
or if I have, for
example, bad weather.
More people can end up end
up happening in the ER.
So these are kind of on
the operational side.
Another operational
example of analytics
is I'm putting a patient in
the medical imaging machine.
I want to make sure that
they are positioned properly,
so that I don't need
to call them again,
because the test was done badly.
So this is an example
where the AI can help
me identify the positioning.
There is also the other side,
which is clinical applications.
These are much more complex,
require of course more
validation to go through FDA.
We have customers and
partners developing these.
As well, some are using
some of our tools.
So a couple of tools that
I want to point out here.
AutoML is a tool that allows
you to very quickly develop
AI models, with relatively
limited AI expertise.
So if you have a team
that has access to data,
we can show you how to
use AutoML to train models
on your data.
If you have a team that has
a little bit more expertise
and you want to
fine tune the model,
then the Cloud Machine
Learning Engine
might be a better tool for that.
So naturally, I would
not expect AutoML
to produce clinical
prediction value models.
But with combination of using
AutoML and using Cloud Machine
Learning Engine for
fine tuning, you
can get something
that can be useful.
And then finally
on the ML piece,
I'll mention that one of
the challenges that we
see in the space is that
a lot of people building
AI applications.
Some companies literally have
like one or two algorithms,
and they are trying
to kind of see
if there is a market for it.
So we chose kind of
a meta approach here,
and what I mean by that is that
we are building a tool that
would enable you to evaluate
different types of AI models.
So if you have a
model that claims
to be able to detect
brain bleed, for example,
and there is another
model that claims
to be able to do the same,
how do you compare them?
How do you measure the
performance of them?
On the application
side, I mentioned
a couple of open-source
tools that we've integrated
and enabled researchers to use.
These are some
open-source viewers,
that you can run on top.
If your store your
data on our cloud,
you can use these viewers
and visualize it, presented
for your research purposes.
These are some of the
de-identification tools
that I mentioned.
So MIRC CTP and DICOM
cleaner, in the context
of medical imaging.
This is kind of
the best practice.
These tools have
been [INAUDIBLE]
more than a decade ago.
But this is still what you
see, encounter in practice,
when people are trying to
de-identify medical data.
So what we have done is
we've built our tool,
we integrated these
tools with our back end,
and we offer to our
customers and partners
to select them, and see
what works for them best.
This is just a screenshot
from the AI model browser
that I mentioned.
The idea would be here that
you can select an application,
and select a data
set, and you can
evaluate, run this application
on top of a data set,
and evaluate, compare to
specific applications.
We also want to
educate the community
and help people develop
their own AI applications,
so we have published several
tutorials on how to do that.
The example here
is super simple.
You will never confuse this with
a real clinical application.
So we built a classification
model for breast density.
So the reason it's
relevant clinically
is that breast density can be
a predictor of breast cancer
risk.
So it's usually
scored between one,
means less dense,
and four, more dense.
And we have created
a tutorial that
shows how you can use
publicly available data set
to create a binary
classification between two
types of density.
So this is the
resource that this is.
You can evaluate the different,
the performance of the model,
and you can tweak it.
I'll leave this-- oh,
actually the link is not here.
And not only you can
develop this application,
we will also show you how
to deploy this application
and connect it to the
clinical workflow.
Because if you develop
the best application,
but the doctor doesn't have
access to it, that's a problem.
So there are tools that
we are working on exactly
for this purpose.
So this was my final slide.
I want to invite back Dr.
Yoshino to kind of summarize,
and thank you for
your time today.
[APPLAUSE]
TAKAYUKI YOSHINO:
So thank you, Arie.
Thank you, Arie.
OK, thank you very
much for coming.
We would like to summarize
this, the presentation,
more focusing on the
virtual sequencing.
So [INAUDIBLE] Arie mentioned so
many examples of the AI device,
but the current device are
designed to support the doctor
judgement only.
However, more concerning
the virtual sequencing,
you can see here, against
the virtual sequence,
exceed real energy sequence,
in the near future.
Currently we are
now the communicate
between the doctors and AI.
Sorry, AI know right,
also be important science
level, especially
with a pathology,
and pathologist also be input
[INAUDIBLE] and notation,
so the cooperation between
the doctor and the AI
is needed to get the [INAUDIBLE]
doctor in the [INAUDIBLE]..
But I am confident,
based on our experience,
a bunch of sequence
in the near future
exceed real sequence,
more happy life, I guess.
So virtual sequence is making
a brighter future possible,
I [INAUDIBLE].
To prompt outright diagnosis,
and optimal treatment,
enable a global access to
quality cancer diagnostic,
and [INAUDIBLE] effort, the
saving costs [? uncertain. ?]
So this is our
conclusion in my slide.
And finally I would
like to show you
our SCRUM-Japan GENESIS team,
and so many Japanese doctors.
And he's Dr. [? Kotani ?] here.
[? Kotani ?] here?
OK?
He's here.
And Dr. [? Yamata, ?]
Mr. [? Yamata, ?]
he's the general media company.
And also Papara Suzuki.
Mr. Suzuki here.
And he's the company [? papa. ?]
And Dr. Fuji here, he's
an excellent pathology.
And so many members here.
I'm sorry.
I'm ashamed of myself.
OK.
Finally I would like to
thank you for coming here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]